while the majority of the halo media is
based on the 26th century
the universe behind the games spans
hundreds of thousands of years
so with this i'm going to attempt to sum
up the entire story into a short
easily digestible video bringing us to
the current timeline in the story
as of the end of halo 5 guardians
over 10 million years ago an advanced
civilization known as the precursors
controlled the galaxy having rained for
billions of years
and reaching the pinnacle of
technological advancement they seated
the galaxy with life
and created many species including
humans and forerunners
the precursors held the mantle of
responsibility the guardianship of all
life in the galaxy
and they decided it was time to pass the
mantle down to one of their creations
initially it was the forerunners who
were selected but over time
the precursors changed their minds and
handed it to humanity instead
this angered the forerunners and they
went on to declare war on the precursors
although they were considerably more
advanced the precursors
taken by surprise were almost completely
wiped out
some of the precursors survived by
transforming themselves into a molecular
dust
that they will be able to use to
regenerate themselves sometime in the
future
but after millions of years this dust
would become corrupted
and infected those who came into contact
with it would mutate
this was the beginning of the parasitic
flood
ancient humanity stumble across the
flood parasite near the galaxy's edges
hundreds of human planets were quickly
lost to the parasite
humanity desperate to stop the spread
started sterilizing their own planets to
slow its advancement
all while securing more colonies for the
populations to relocate to
unfortunately this aggressive expansion
towards forerunner territory
was perceived as an act of war humanity
was now on a two-front war
against the flood and the forerunners
despite this humanity was eventually
able
to push the flood out of the galaxy
however
the forerunners led by the supreme
commander known as the didact
dismantled humanity's civilization and
eventually emerged victorious
humanity was regressed to a
hunter-gatherer level species
and was exiled to their home world earth
where they would essentially start over
[Music]
the flood resurface and for the first
time the forerunners make contact with
them
resulting in a war that lasts for
centuries
many forerunner planets have been
overwhelmed by the flood
they decide that the only way to stop
the complete infection of the galaxy
is to remove its food source and end all
known sentient life
the forerunners create a super weapon
called the halo array
which is a network of enormous rings
throughout the galaxy
the dna of each species would be stored
so that after the cleansing of the flood
from the system
planets could be reseeded and begin once
again
this weapon was a success once fired
all beings within the array's effective
range including the forerunners
themselves
were wiped out
almost one hundred thousand years later
the sanction and the sangheili
spent years locked in a bitter war over
the control of the remains of the
forerunners
the prophets wished to use this
technology to search and explore the
galaxy
but the elites believed such usage to be
a desecration of the holy artifacts
eventually the two species formed an
alliance that would be known
for centuries to come as the covenant
over time many other species would be
absorbed into their ranks
modern humankind began colonizing the
solar system
creating settlements on the moon and
mars as well as various asteroids and
moons of jupiter
[Music]
governance and factions fight for
control of earth and its early colonies
overpopulation and disorder on earth
begin to mount
the united nations space command is
created to deal with the growing
rebellions spanning the solar system
eventually treaties are signed and the
interplanetary wars
end a united earth government is formed
but they are now facing problems of
overpopulation famine
and economic instability caused by the
wars
with now over 800 settled worlds across
the milky way galaxy
humanity's golden age of expansion was
about to come to an end
but with its rapid spread the outer less
wealthy colonies
began to feel isolated laws and taxes
set up by the united earth governments
were causing dissent
and instability against the centralized
earth government
outer colonies were feeling like it was
becoming their role to work hard
and live in squalor in order for the
wealthy inner colonies
to continue their more luxurious
lifestyles
this eventually led to the insurrection
an undeclared civil war
between the unsc and the various rebel
groups that rose up against it
the insurrection led to the unsc to
create the spartan 2 project
this program would take 75 physically
and mentally gifted children
into rigorous training and physical
augmentations through surgical and
medical means
these super soldiers codenamed spartans
were given the task
of squashing the rebellion because time
was a factor
but also the need to maintain secrecy
around the program
these 75 children were kidnapped and
replaced with flash clones
who would die shortly after once the
children had met physical maturity
the biological augmentation process
would begin
this part of the program was tough and
almost immediately
30 of them died as a result of the
procedure with a further 12 of the
candidates
being left permanently crippled
first contact between humanity and the
covenant is made
the prophets discover that the humans
were pretty much the living ears to the
ones the covenant worship as gods
the foreigners realizing that this will
pose a threat to their authority as well
as their religion
they hide the truth from the rest of the
covenant and call for the complete
destruction of all humanity
claiming that humans had committed
unforgivable offences against the gods
the human covenant war begins
the spartan 3 project is begun in secret
this time the children experimented on
are orphans from worlds who have been
attacked by the covenant
and are considered expendable
the artificial intelligence cortana has
created
cloned from the brain of the spartan 2
program creator
dr catherine halsey
the covenant invade reach one of
humanity's most populated planets
the spartans of noble team help a unsc
ship the pillar of autumn
escape the ship carries the ai known as
cortana
who holds information from an ancient
artifact
the pillar of autumn crashes onto one of
the forerunner's halo arrays
and a sample of the flood kept in
quarantine is awakened
to stop the flood and prevent the halo
array from being activated
spartan john 117 master chief destroys
the ring
the covenant go on to invade earth but
is stopped by the unsc
while fleeing master chief with cortana
aboard the unsc
ship in amber clad decides to follow
them to another halo installation that
the covenant are planning to activate
along with the disgraced member of the
covenant known as the arbiter
chief once again puts a stop to the
covenant plans
a device known as the forerunner arc is
discovered on earth
this installation is used to control the
halo arrays
the covenant unsc and the flood all
fight for control
but cortana arrives via a portal that
leads to another arc
beyond the limits of the galaxy she
leads master chief through the portal
followed by the flood along with a
number of covenant
cortana has constructed a new halo there
which master chief uses to destroy the
ark and those on it before leaving on
the ship
forward and to dawn but while escaping
the ship is torn in half and both the
master chief and cortana
are set adrift throughout space
a truce brings an end to the human
covenant war
[Music]
a planet called requiem draws the
remnants of the fordham to dawn into its
orbit
cortana is now suffering from rampancy
which is a condition that begins to
affect ai who live beyond their normal
lifespan
this former forerunner planet is home to
a general called the didact
who's been held there in suspended
animation
having drifted through space for over
four years cortana notices that the
ship's intruder alarms have been
activated
and wakes the chief from cryosleep
after crash landing on the planet the
chief and cortana
are engaged by the occupying covenant
forces who have refused to disarm
and continues to declare war on humanity
after the didact awoke the covenant
group swears allegiance to him
the didact plans to use the composer a
machine that translates
an organic being's mental content into
machine data
to attack earth and grows promethean
army
the master chief follows him in close
pursuit
but the diadect was too powerful for the
master chief
however cortana nearing the end of her
life uses the last of her strength to
immobilize him
and it was during this time that the
chief was able to disable the didact
with a pulse grenade
sending him falling into a slip space
rupture beneath the composer cortana was
able to save the master chief
from the subsequent blast that was used
to destroy the composer
cortana then begins to fade away
floating around space
the chief is later recovered by the unsc
infinity
cortana was still within the didx ship
when it was destroyed by the master
chief
what was left of the ship enacted an
emergency slipspace jump
and came out near genesis where cortana
discovered the domain
after accessing the domain she was able
to stop her rampancy
and gain control of all four runner
assets
she begins to awaken the guardians
powerful forerunner ais
as a way of forcibly bringing peace to
the galaxy
she essentially assumes the mantle of
responsibility
the master chief was supposed to return
home but after receiving a message from
cortana
he had hoped that he could find her
requesting permission to retrieve her
he was denied but the chief disobeys
orders
and sets off with blue team to find
cortana
having gone awol spartan fire team
osiris
was sent to bring them back to the
united nations space command
however after finding out the truth
about cortana and the guardians
they realized blue team would need help
ai from across the galaxy began swearing
allegiance to cortana in her plans
she arrives on earth with one of her
guardians and uses its emp
to shut down most of the planet's power
and defenses but not before the infinity
flees earth's orbit it would appear that
the unsc
and earth has been forced back into the
dark ages
and this is where it can be assumed that
the story will continue on to halo
infinite
i'm a massive halo fan although i've
played everything in the franchise i put
an obsessive amount of time into halo 3.
so when it was suggested by a number of
people that i consider exploring the
enormous halo universe
i jumped at the idea i'm not sure how
well this will be received but i'm going
to give it an honest shot
even if just for my own interests but
please let me know what you think
this has obviously just been an overly
shortened version of the story up until
now
but i'm really keen to start working
through some of the depth the story has
to offer
thank you very much for watching and
i'll catch you in the next one cheers
you